hey everyone this is jeremy shifling at
khan academy um thank you so much for
making time out of your busy back to
school season to join us today you know
there's a ton going on in your class and
in the world and so i want to make the
next 30 minutes really valuable
and to that end i'm going to focus not
on just another lecture or another
presentation but specifically a guide to
making those
zoom lessons those google meet lessons
those live video lessons you're going to
be doing all fall really effective for
your students and so i'm going to be
presenting a sample lesson to you as my
quasi students right now
that being said before we get started i
do want to lay out a couple of things so
number one the question i always have on
my mind whenever i'm starting a webinar
is can i get a copy of this can i see
the slides absolutely so i'll be
recorded and shared in your email inbox
in about an hour so look for that no
matter what
and then number two the number the sort
of most common questions i got from
folks leading up to the session is hey i
teach seventh grade not sixth grade or i
teach social studies not math is this
still relevant
absolutely i was actually a former
kindergarten teacher before i joined
khan so even teaching sixth grade math
is a little bit out of my comfort zone
but the key is not about the content
itself but the pedagogical principles
about how do you use this new format
this new kind of zoom session to be
really effective
and speaking of that even though we now
sort of use zoom as a generic term to
encapsulate capsulate all video
conference the way we used to do for
xerox with copy machines or kleenex with
tissues
what i really mean is whether you're
using zoom google meet cisco webex or
some other platform like go to webinar
just know that all these principles
apply because they're less about
technology and more about human
psychology about how students learn and
how teachers can teach their best in
this new environment so no matter what
you teach no matter what tools you use
to teach this will be highly relevant
for you heading into the fall
okay that being said
the frame for today's session is this a
really awesome op-ed that sal khan wrote
a couple weeks back
and i'm not just saying that because sal
is my boss and he signs my checks but
because i really do believe again as a
former kindergarten teacher who is all
about engaging his students and getting
them interacting in the classroom
that when we think about teaching in
this new environment it's so easy to
psych ourselves out and say hey
i'm really uncomfortable and unfamiliar
with these technology technology tools
you know i'm going to have to fall back
on sort of the lowest common denominator
giving lectures broadcasting my lessons
and i think that if we push ourselves a
little bit as educators we say we know
what great education looks like
especially in a regular classroom
we know that it's not about lectures and
monologues it's about conversations and
dialogues getting students thinking
getting them talking getting them
learning
and so sal sort of clarion call
is how can we bring that same level of
interactivity that same level of
engagement from the in-person classroom
to the online classroom and that's what
i'm going to try to demo for you today
so the first thing that it really calls
out in this op-ed and i'll share this
out in the email afterwards you can read
his op-ed directly but i pulled out some
valuable quotes here
is that
maybe because of the school district
pressures folks were getting in the
spring or because we were all sort of
running around with our heads chopped
off i know i certainly was trying to get
stuff done at khan academy
we kind of got into this mode of let's
record a bunch of videos send them out
to our students
and that'll be the best way we can
engage them in this really difficult
moment
and the reality is is that if you're
spending a lot of your time recording
videos but not actually interacting with
students
you're kind of reinventing the wheel
because
sal and others have been making these
videos for 10 years or more at this
point and so if there's any topic in the
world that you want to share with your
students chances are you can find it on
khan academy you can find it on youtube
you can find it on other platforms so
why just replicate those lectures
instead use that scarce time you have
online to really get your students
plugged in
thinking engaging not just sitting back
with their minds turned off so number
one prioritize interaction
and the best way you can do that just to
give you a little sort of hint is you
can assign all sorts of video and
practice content to folks on khan
academy even before your zoom session
so i mentioned in my email if you saw
this meeting into this webinar i said
hey do me a favor
watch this video on multiplication word
problems and then also do this exercise
on multiplication and division word
problems
and if you want to replicate that same
thing with your own students you can
come right over here say check this
check that
and then assign to my students
i can give you more information about
how to sort of use con but actually
that's not so much the focus today is
get that out of the way get that taken
care of and then move on to the more
important things the more fun things
frankly which is engaging your students
so to that point let's move to sal's
second point which is when you
prioritize interaction
don't just immediately go into academic
mode okay we're going to talk about math
or we're going to talk about social
studies
instead give students a chance to really
process things on the social emotional
front front and i know that scl has been
hot in the last couple years
academically speaking but never more so
than the last six months because we know
that our students have a ton on their
shoulders right now so we want to give
them an outlet for creativity for
imagination for social connection for
joy
all those things that can seem really
hard especially in a digital environment
and to help you with that
khan has put together a brand new tool
called khan academy refresh
and basically what this is is over a
hundred conversation starters you can
use at the start of a long zoom session
or if you're changing between two topics
and you need a little chance to again
refresh and shake things up
and what i would love to do to start off
this session today again putting you in
that student mode
is everyone check out this really good
prompt here i love this one
describe the year 2020 as a food
what would it taste like and why
and if you can share that in the
question section that would be amazing
so um on go to webinar there's a little
section called questions we can actually
put in your questions
and just describe that year
as a food
what do you think 2020 would taste like
if you dug into it and why go ahead and
answer that there and obviously you can
do the exact same thing on pretty much
any video platform
zoom has chat google meet has chat web
access chat so it should be a very
familiar kind of way to get your
students talking so i'm going to shout
out some of the stuff that i love i love
the fact first of all that connie and
karen both said liver they were the
first ones to answer and so obviously as
educators we are all tuned in to sort of
the way that 2020 tastes right now um
hopefully it's also nutritious like a
liver in some ways but we'll see um greg
says haggis definitely hear that
if i think 2020 was described as a food
talking about it as a boiled pig stomach
or a lamp cow stomach certainly makes
sense
tiffany also says liver
meridian says sour patch kids sweet and
sour i love that meridian was able to
find some sweetness amongst all the sour
experiences
gloria says cod liver oil because it's
so nasty tasting
adriana and cheryl both say lemons um
adriana adds because it has some sour
times and sometimes we were not too
happy about absolutely
donna says moldy cheese it should be so
good this should be the most amazing
year 2020 it sounds like the future but
it just ain't um and then i'm gonna say
a couple others here we've got um
raymond saying ghost pepper definitely
we feel burned this year
um becky says broccoli and i'll leave
that open to interpretation i know some
people love broccoli out there
john says sauerkraut and bratwurst
because it takes a lot of gumption to
eat it but it ends up being satisfying
if you try it okay i have to end on that
one john because you've nailed it this
is definitely the most challenging year
across every industry across every part
of our society but i think what we're
going to sort of learn from this
experience over the next several months
is we can actually teach ourselves new
skills as educators and they can
actually make us stronger as teachers
for years going forward if we invest in
them now so i love that attitude
so i want to build on that going into
the next section
which is bridging the offline and the
online experience for your students
so one of the things that sal says is
like look realistically you can't be on
zoom all day no matter what your
district tells you you have to do
it's going to be too much for your
students too much for you and so you're
going to have to have some work done
asynchronously in other words have
students watch some videos offline or do
some work offline kind of like i was
suggesting in that first step
but here's the key
i think you have to then use the
information you get from assigning all
that stuff offline
and then reconnect it when you reconvene
as a class in your zoom sessions so that
way for a student they don't feel like
okay this is just some busy work to get
me through the day and it has no bearing
on what my teacher is talking about
instead
this stuff that i'm working on on the
side offline is absolutely critical to
what we're going to do online when we
come together as a class
and sort of demonstrate what i think is
possible there i want to show you um
what it looks like on the khan academy
back end this is available to everyone
on this call as a teacher
because it says hey you went ahead and
assigned some practice to your students
the same way that i assigned practice to
you before this session
i said i want you to go ahead and do
this
multiplication division word problem
practice so you can come in ready to go
and one of the really cool things that
khan academy will show you once you've
had students do this offline
is now online you can look at their
performance
and better yet you can see number one
which of these questions are students
really struggling with and so in my sort
of sample classroom
every question was awesome except for
question three
and specifically you can show your
students what the responses from the
class were so they can say hey that's my
response i'm not alone others are
thinking the same thing
and so once you start to identify some
of the challenges and the understanding
of the problem and how to process it now
you can tackle it as a whole class
this is kind of like x-ray vision for
teachers
because unlike before when maybe you
just had to guess you know who was
thinking differently or who might need a
little extra help now you can sing a
single place this is the sort of common
area where our whole class is struggling
let's really focus on that with our
limited time together
and so
to sort of walk you through this i want
to make it really interactive again to
sal's point i'm going to give you some
poll questions
along the way i'm going to show you how
you can do it in any platform in a
second
so let's look at this question together
class i talked about ron and hermione
from one of our favorite books
and they're using their new magic skills
from hogwarts to lift feathers into the
air
now hermione the problem tells us can
lift a feather
3 525 centimeters into the air not too
shabby she knows her stuff
however
it's really impressive because that is
five times as high as ron can lift his
feather
and so our question is
how high can ron lift the feather with
his magic
now to really break this down i want to
do this first one as a class
so i want to ask you an initial question
you're going to see this on your screen
in a second
which is
before we even get into the mechanics of
it what kind of problem is this
is this addition is it subtraction
multiplication division is it some kind
of hogwarty and magic problem
let me know what you think i just want
to get a sense of where everyone's heads
are at before we dive a little further
okay see a lot of folks voting this is
awesome
um and really like don't worry about
whether you've nailed it or not just go
ahead and guess
because i want to get a sense of where
where we are as a class community before
we dive in
all right three two one we're going to
close this poll
i'm going to share the results with you
and you can see that the
majority of the folks in class are
saying division but a big chunk are
saying multiplication some are even
saying magic so let's talk about it a
little bit
um before we talk about it let me just
explain this is yes a cool feature of go
to webinar zoom has something similar
google meet may not have polls built in
but no matter what platform you're using
using free google docs tools you can
come over here and basically add any
kind of question onto your screen and
have students vote either through the
chat function or through this and here's
a cool little hack for you if you ever
want to start a new google form you can
send to your students to test how
they're doing all you have to do is type
form dot new into your browser
and that will start a brand new survey
that you can send out so whether you
have fancy technology or non-fancy
technology it doesn't matter there are
always ways to work around
okay that being said um let's talk about
this question a little bit class
so it's definitely tricky because we're
studying multiplication and division
word problems at the same time
and you can easily see it going one way
or uh or the other especially because it
uses this word five times which sounds
kind of like multiplication
but the key thing here is we're saying
that actually hermione is lifting hers
higher than ron is
and if hers is higher this has got to be
a division problem because we got to
figure out how much less
ron can lift his feather with his magic
so the division folks are right on in
this case but now i want to ask another
question
which is okay we know it's division
because we're focused on breaking this
bigger number down into something
smaller in this case ron's number
but how would you go about setting it up
and again check out a couple different
ways to do it on your screen
and think about which one of these
approaches is the correct one based on
the fact that we now agree it's a
division problem
should we start with a larger number
start with a smaller number
what makes the most sense
and what should we divide by of course
by
five times as high
by two characters what do you think
okay thanks everyone for voting so fast
this is awesome
go ahead and share those results
and this time i'm really happy to say
you all nailed it
we know that hermione got her feather
astonishing 3 525 centimeters into the
air so that's going to be the top number
in our formula and then we also know
that ron was 5 times less so that's
going to be the bottom number in our
formula so that's what we're going to
focus on beautifully done
and now
we're going to actually talk about
the last step here so hold on one second
um
what is the answer
and so
i want to have this be a little more
interactive so first of all go ahead and
do your own
calculation so let me know what you
think
is ron
um at 705 centimeters
a little more than 17 000 centimeters
881 and a quarter centimeters or is ron
just bad at magic in general so it's not
even worth calculating
okay i love everyone answering so fast
this is awesome i'm going to close the
poll i'm going to share the results
and you all nailed it um i'm definitely
going to send you some digital
certificates after this so thank you for
your awesome work today so great job
class now just to explain for those who
might feel a little bit frustrated at
this point okay 705 that sounds good but
how do we get there what i actually want
to do is i want to draw now i want to
show you exactly how i got this answer
by coming over to the draw section
i think this is so powerful for your
students because
you're amazing on the whiteboard of the
chalkboard in your class
but a lot of times it can feel like oh i
don't have that
in my classroom
digitally so what do i do well the nice
thing is if you're sharing your screen
and again you can do that on pretty much
any platform you can always come over to
the draw section and literally just
start writing on the screen
um and so what we'll do is we'll set
this up so we've got
35 25
right there in the middle
we're going to divide
5 into that
we know 5 can't go into 3 but 5 can go
into 35 seven times
so we put in our 35
bring that down to zero
five can't go into two so we're going to
put a zero there but it can go into 25
five times
so we have 705 5 times 5 is 25
and we're down to zero with no remainder
so i have to apologize for my sloppy
handwriting um i will say i'm doing this
completely with my uh my mouse over here
but if you want to pick up a wacom
tablet like the one that sal khan uses
to make videos it's about 50 bucks right
now on amazon i noticed
and we're also always giving them away
from kind of academy as well so um that
will definitely make your uh handwriting
a little bit more legible than mine you
can just imagine how my poor
kindergarten students fared given my
handwriting but um definitely a cool
tool to again get that whiteboard feel
back in your class
okay that being said i want to move on
to the last point that sal made which is
you want to get your students thinking
and you especially want to get them
thinking aloud and that's because as
every math teacher knows out there even
if you don't teach math even if you
teach anything else
you know that the best learning the best
sort of progress and growth comes when
students struggle not just guessing an
answer and being lucky but really
forcing them to not just sit back
passively but to engage actively and so
what sal highly recommends is
ask your students questions get them to
share their thinking even cold call them
a little bit
in a friendly sort of non-antagonistic
way just to make sure that they feel
plugged into what you're doing and
they're not just sitting back passively
watching the show
and to do that
i will say that khan is a real sort of
wealth of really great questions you can
ask your students
some of them in the practice section as
you notice are fairly easy and that's by
design we don't want to intimidate
students
but in the videos we have some pretty
juicy questions um i think you can
always steal these and just put them on
your screen if you really want to give
a really interesting brain teaser to
your students
so we're going to pull up this question
which is blair scored 144 points this
football season so fingers crossed the
football season still goes on
blair scored all of his points with 50
yard field goal kicks for three point
seats not bad blair sounds like quite
the uh quite the kicker
um and he played in 16 games this season
how many field goals did blair make in
each game this is a two-step problem now
and it's going to take a little doing
now here's what i'm going on a limb as a
facilitator of this class
is there anyone in the audience who
would be game for me to turn on their
audio right now and we can just go back
and forth on this question and i'll
diagram out your answer on my little
digital whiteboard as we go along
um and i would just love to sort of talk
with you about your thought process how
you put it together and we'll use this
as a learning moment for all of our
classmates who are also trying to figure
this out so if you're interested in
being our volunteer today
all you have to do is click the hand
raise button on your go to webinar
control panel i will go and open up your
audio and we'll have a quick chat
so again raise your hand
and let's dig in
okay so i believe that eric was first so
let me give eric a shot
hey eric are you there
yes
hey eric are you are you willing to be a
brave volunteer today
yeah let me find you on my screen i
can't find you
i went to i was i went to the khan
academy site there there you are okay
yeah oh yeah don't worry sorry for all
the multitasking here um eric tell us a
little bit about what you teach and
where you're based
i teach uh high school geometry
and calculus in freiburg maine oh wow so
cool well you were gonna crush this one
especially compared to a former
kindergarten teacher
and i wasn't i was off task for a minute
let's see okay no worries well
while while you look at this question i
want to pull up another cool little hack
for you all which is again if you've got
zoom there's a built-in whiteboard
feature but there's no built-in
whiteboard feature for go to webinars
what am i going to do well i find a hack
i find a workaround and sure enough
there's this free site called
whiteboardfox.com
you just go there you start a new
session again without paying a cent
without even registering and now you
have a whiteboard to draw on so
um eric if you had a chance to look at
this question just tell me how you get
started how would you even begin um
taking on this problem
uh
so there's uh they they have some
extraneous information he explored all
these points with the 50-yard
50-yard field goal kick so students are
gonna look at that number and they're
gonna wonder what do i do with that 50
which are worth three points each he
played 16 games there they were they all
scored all his points were three
were field goals or uh
okay he played in 16 how many field
goals did he make in each game
wow
144
divided by three
is
all right let's do that yeah
okay
uh 4
12
24
3 goes into 48 let me just check 48
times 3. yeah so uh
he scored 40 he scored 40
uh he he kicked 48 field goals okay
beautiful and uh if he played in 16
games then you would divide that by 16.
okay so now we have 48
divided by 16. and of course it might be
easier just to sort of think about
multiples of 16. so the answer is
uh well 32 uh three
three three field goals per game not bad
at all
yeah and so eric like that was amazing
like you totally just sort of walked us
through how to break that down yeah but
then you want to check you know you want
to check so if he scored three foot
field goals per game he scored nine
points per game correct that's right
exactly so now
nine times 16 and see if that adds up to
that's right there we go
yeah
okay beautiful um
so
eric
i want you live if you don't mind um do
you feel like this would be a doable
strategy for your students or are you
doing it already or planning to do it i
plan on doing it but what i'm really
interested in is all the technology how
you showed your writing and all those
little icons up above there that you're
clicking are they available on the khan
academy
lessons
yeah great question so i highly highly
recommend
using this um
sort of review format with your students
the reason is that you're able to sort
of again connect the online to the
offline by saying hey here are the
questions that we all just did as a
class yeah hear everyone's answers and
then without going to another site or
even pulling up the zoom whiteboard
feature you have this draw section built
right in so it's really like one-stop
shopping
okay it's great it's beautiful
yeah and if you're like me and you're
like even struggling with like oh my
goodness like how do i explain all this
you can even go to the insects and kind
of break it down a little further if you
want wow i think you all will probably
be many steps ahead of me mathematically
yeah that's beautiful
yeah
and i think it just you know let
students know also that there's like
hunger for connection right now like
they're feeling like oh my goodness is
my teacher even seeing what i'm doing do
they care what i'm doing and the fact
that you can literally show their
responses on the screen albeit
anonymously says hey they're paying
attention and it does matter what i'm
doing
cool
okay so eric thank you so much for being
an amazing volunteer you totally rocked
this one
thank you
okay so i'm gonna mute eric's line for a
second here
um
i want to come to the sort of recap of
what we just discussed and also give
folks a chance to ask additional
questions as well
so if you come back to sort of sal's
call to action if you will he was really
calling out four things for
for educators he was saying number one
let's go back to first principles
no one got into teaching to be a
lecturer you got in it to be a
stimulator an inspirer getting students
interacting every day in your class
let's prioritize that before we do
anything else with technology
number two recognizing that times are
tough can't just be all academics all
the time so use tools like khan academy
refresh or just conversation starters or
how was your weekend to have students
have a chance to talk to each other
share their ideas be creative again
number three
offload a lot of the heavy lifting
lecture wise to asynchronous work so
assign those videos on con assign those
practice sessions on con get them doing
stuff before they come into the live
session
and then when they come in
make that bridge between what they've
done offline with what you're going to
talk about online so like eric was just
talking about show them what they have
done
explain where they might need a little
help and get them thinking and sharing
their ideas
and then lastly don't just say sit back
and answer a lot of pull questions
because that's a good start but get them
really talking about their thinking
talking about their process
and you can do that by cold calling
students by giving everyone a chance to
talk during the course of a session just
get them talking and sharing which is
always the most engaging way to get
those brains turned on and activated
so that being said um i would love to
answer any questions you might have
about the technology about
the pedagogical approach or about khan
academy itself
i'm happy to answer those via the
question section so i'm going to go
right down to that right now i'm just
going to start taking them as they come
in so if you have a question feel free
to type it type it in and i will respond
right away
so
um font says can google forms give you
immediate pull feedback absolutely
so if i was to go ahead and share this
with my students what i could do is i
could actually
generate this link so i click send i say
i've got my little poll ready i'm going
to copy this and paste it into the chat
or whatever i'm using and then what i'll
see on the back end is the response is
live as they come in and that's again
pretty powerful even if you don't have
some fancy pull function built into your
platform so definitely check it out and
again the shortcut is
um
form.new and you can start a new form at
any point great question font
okay let's see here
so john is asking what kind of digital
pad does sal khan use with a pen i'm
actually going to share this with you
all right now so check this out so first
of all i'm going to share a couple
things number one this is the khan help
center where if you ever have any
questions you can always come and get
your answers answered
so in this case i'll say
wacom which is the tablet he uses
and sure enough
here's all of sal's current setup
camtasia smooth draw wacom
but again you can buy one of these for
50 bucks on amazon so if you're
interested feel free to grab that
and then lastly i do want to call this
out if you're not finding what you need
please let us know right away i know it
sounds negative to report a problem but
know that you can come here for
questions for ideas for suggestions
and we typically respond in a couple of
hours
so please take advantage of this feature
if you're getting stumped with anything
along the way
great question john
okay um
oh vicky so vicky is actually our head
of development at khan academy she's
asking is there an ideal number of
students for a lesson like this
so here's the interesting thing vicky we
actually have more than 200 educators
across the nation live right now which
just shows that anything is possible if
you sort of plan things out and focus on
that interactivity
that being said i think it would be even
more fun if you were doing this with a
class of 25 or 30 or 35 students and you
could see your students video people
were talking more frequently so um if
you do have a large lecture maybe you
teach at a community college totally get
it it's doable but obviously a smaller
class allows for even more interactivity
great question vicki
um
let's see here um
so
um gloria said what is the name of the
tool for writing on the whiteboard and
again if you just want to use khan
academy's built-in tool
that's under the assignment score
section so let me show you how to get
here just so it's super easy for you
um if you ever come to your teacher
dashboard and you're looking at your
class
you're going to come down to the
assignment section come over to scores
and then you're going to choose the
specific assignment that you gave in
this case here's the one that i gave to
you all before the session
and then you click draw and you've got
that whiteboard ready to go
that being said
if you want a brand new one you can come
over to whiteboardfox.com
say start drawing create a whiteboard
and voila without registering without
paying a cent i've got a whiteboard to
use on my screen right now
and again i don't necessarily endorse
one product over another
but i think in this moment we all need
really good tools really free tools and
so that's one that i highly recommend
okay great question gloria
um
let's see here
um
rosemary is saying what do you think
about assessing how well students know
their basic multiplication facts
i have always increased fluency with how
many facts can you answer in five
minutes on paper and pencil
and so what i might suggest on rose or
mary is
you could use something like google
forms because i totally agree you know
multiplication facts are so foundational
to everything that we do including the
problem that eric and i just worked on
there and the fact that eric knew his
multiplication facts from having an
amazing third grade teacher um means
that he was able to do that question so
quickly
and so i think you really do want to
focus on that speed of processing as
well as the memorization
is you could actually build out a whole
question bank right here you know five
times five seven times nine etc you
could give it to your students and you
could literally put a timer on hey
you've got to get this done in a certain
amount of time
here's another cool little tack if you
want to have a timer on your screen
you come over here to five minute timer
in google
and google will start a timer for you
automatically that you can share on your
screen so your students know how much
time is left again super easy way to get
started
and get your students working really
fast and i'll share a link to that
technique in the chat great question
rosemary i love multiplication facts
um
let's see here don is asking what did
you mean by the review section is that a
part of khan academy absolutely so
um this scores report
is again baked into every assignment
that you give on khan academy where it's
going to tell you a couple of things
number one it's going to tell you which
of the problems were the toughest for
your students
then it's going to show you the actual
responses from your students so in this
case we could start to say ah students
are consistently getting this wrong with
the exact wrong answer
maybe i can intuit where they're going
wrong they're doing multiplication
instead of division
and then we can get into all the other
stuff that we've already shared and
that's all available all free for every
teacher out there um it's a great
question donna
um let's see here
um
[Music]
what is the name of the one on amazon
says georgina so um wacom i would say is
sort of like the again the xerox or the
kleenex or the zoom of tablets based on
what i've seen
um and they have a new one called the
wacom one
o-n-e um the one that we have given out
in the past or the one that sal uses is
often used by professional designers
it's got tons of sensitivity you can do
shading new gradients all this fancy
stuff and that's great if that's what
you're trying to do
but if all you want to do is draw on the
screen this waycom1 is only 50 bucks and
it does allow you to sort of get all the
basic stuff done without a lot of fancy
features you don't need so you might
want to check that out
okay
um adriana says you mentioned khan
giving away some tablets where can i
find that so i'm happy to say that our
con for educators campaign which was a
little contest or giveaway tied to the
launch of our new conf educators course
just gave out
15 of those fancier tablets and we will
absolutely do more like that in the near
future
in the meantime if you want to check out
any of that training material
here's what that course looks like
and it'll go way more in depth on all
the things we just talked about how do
you give assignments how do you look at
those reports how do you figure out what
your students are doing so i highly
recommend con for educators it's the
best way to learn con you can do it all
in an hour or two and you get a
certificate for your time okay great
question on adriana
um
let's see here
um
[Music]
oh ed has a great great point probably
you always have math examples can you
provide an english sample absolutely so
i promise that my next session will be
focused on maybe ela maybe social
studies
my wife is a
historian herself so she's gonna i'm
gonna be in big trouble if i don't focus
on that but um if you ever wanna find
our full breadth of curriculum you can
always go to the courses tab and this
lives everywhere you go on khan academy
no matter whether you're on the teacher
side or the student side you can always
find the courses menu in the upper left
hand corner and you can see this full
spectrum from math to science to ela and
so for example if you're teaching not
6th grade math but 6th grade ela
we've got a ton of stuff already built
out for you and so i highly recommend
checking that out
as well as our additional ela content
great call of edda and i apologize about
that
um
let's see here
timothy says parents at our board
meeting said they don't want that
flipped classroom structure in other
words having students watch videos
offline and then assuming they're coming
in already having watched what would be
a good blended strategy instead of that
and i totally get it you know given the
sort of low participation rates we saw
in the spring there's a legitimate fear
that if you assign something ahead of
time there could be 25 or 30 percent of
your students who never even see it
never even do it you don't want to leave
those students at a disadvantage
so what you can do
is you can maybe give it out as some
optional pre-reading just sort of throw
it out there but then you can kick off
your class after you do the refresh
section
with a live demonstration
and kind of like that example of you
know i do one we do one you do one maybe
you do the first example and you solve
one of these challenging ones that sal
has thrown out but then you quickly go
from just pure sort of lecture mode into
an interactive mode ask some poll
questions get the student's intuition
have a student answer the question all
the way through to really demonstrate
that process i think the more time you
can spend having students thinking
actively the more engagement and the
more learning you're going to get great
question timothy
let's see here
um
linda that's a really good question if i
have a group of students already signed
up for con and i've linked the class to
google classroom what's the most
efficient way to get others to join
so we'll talk about this more in our
next session next week where i'm going
to actually have
teachers log in as students to my own
class and see what com looks like
through the student prism
um but one thing that i highly recommend
if you haven't seen this before is that
we have this nice google classroom
integration where if you come over here
to the students tab in your classroom
you can say hey
my district or i have already done the
hard work of getting everyone integrated
into google classroom i don't want to
reinvent the wheel i don't have to like
register them all over again
and so what you can do quickly is come
over here click add new students click
invite your google classroom connect to
google classroom and you're off to the
races basically pulling in your existing
google classroom class right into khan
academy so hopefully that's the fastest
way linda to get your students up and
running
okay
that being said
i see that there are a bunch more
questions and i don't want to sort of
sort of go too much beyond my welcome
given that i did promise to end um at
the bottom of the hour
let me end with this um number one if
you've got any burning questions and you
want the absolute fastest way to get a
response please reach out to our
world-class support team here's the
amazing thing
thanks to vicky and hers team's work
even as a non-profit at khan academy we
are able to field requests in often
under three or two hours
and so i want you to take advantage of
this team's awesome availability by
submitting questions right here and i'll
put that in the chat
that being said if you don't get your
question answered here you can feel free
to reach out to me directly my email
address will be in the email that comes
to your inbox in about 30 minutes with a
copy of the recording a copy of the
certificate and all the next steps to
get started and i promise i'll get you
an answer even if you don't get it
through this function
that being said i want to close with
something that i really like that sal
mentioned in his op-ed which is
what is the point of school at the end
of the day yes it's about academics yes
it's about learning and growth and all
that good stuff
but it's also where we learn how to be
effective members of society where we
develop those first friendships where we
get inspired to take on big things
and so i think if you can model for your
students
your excitement and your passion for
these topics and a way to get them
engaged and plugged into what you're
excited about
they're going to come out of this year
yes with having overcome so many adverse
challenges
but also with so much excitement for
what's possible and i believe that's
truly what school is all about
so thank you for all that you do thank
you for your amazing questions and
participation tonight and i wish you all
and your students tremendous success in
the year to come thank you so much